the michael knowles public health
protection pledge just got a major boost
on capitol hill yesterday you may recall
a month or so ago i mentioned on this
show that i would not vote for any
candidate for federal office in november
that did not vote to subpoena dr fauci
and to take away his salary a
congressional candidate in north
carolina beau heinz took my off-the-cuff
remark and wrote it up as a formal
pledge at which point dozens of
congressional candidates and sitting
members signed it
then a couple weeks ago arizona
congressman paul gosar entered my pledge
almost verbatim as a formal house
resolution meaning that sitting members
of congress could now sign on
to co-sponsor the bill
at this point
dr fauci basically evaporated into thin
air
that once ubiquitous face
that folksy little voice
that pompous scientific smirk that had
dominated every media platform for two
years
just gone
overnight
the political winds had clearly shifted
against fouchy and he went into hiding
the only thing that was lacking was
support in the senate
which we now have thanks to senator rand
paul
senator paul has actually gone even
further than my pledge called for he has
proposed an amendment that would not
only investigate fauci and stop paying
his salary but would abolish his
position altogether
the paul amendment would reorganize
fouchy's national institute of allergy
and infectious diseases into three
separate research institutes each with
its own director removing entirely the
ability of one power-hungry bureaucrat
to amass the kind of unprecedented power
that fauci took for himself during the
covid lockdowns
this is excellent news
we need to push this over the finish
line do not let the liberals fool you
into thinking that they are done
exercising the unprecedented power that
they took during covid
do not let them fool you into thinking
that they are done with kovid period
they have calmed down now because it's
an election year and the covid policies
are destroying them at the polls but
they've kept the tsa mask mandate
they've kept biden's national emergency
declaration
they've kept the same infrastructure in
place to whip it all back up again the
minute the midterms are behind them do
not let them do it
as we reach the official two-year mark
of 15 days to slow the spread that's
happening tomorrow
call your congressman
call your senator and have them do
everything they can to restore our way
of life and make sure that that little
power mad twerp and his technocrat
buddies never get the chance to shut
your country down again i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from sakuraba 86
who says i kind of miss fouchy
because i absolutely miss fouchy's voice
you're not going to miss him for long
because they're going to bring him back
the minute that it is politically
convenient for them to do so which will
be after the midterm elections that will
happen do not think that fauci is over
you know fauci is a thousand years old
thauchi
or if by some chance he does retire
let's say the republicans win the house
and voucher retires because the
republicans are going to act on the
michael knowles public health protection
pledge if he returns there's just going
to be another fouchy the issue is
structural he's a specifically and
particularly bad dude but there's a
structural issue too and they're going
to bring it back they're already setting
the stage to bring it back do not let
them do it we need to act for ourselves
okay
if we want to protect our country we
need to act for ourselves if we want to
fix our cars we need to act for
ourselves which is why i would recommend
you check out rockauto.com
right now head on over to rockauto.com
and write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s in their
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you you've got to go
over there because your time is valuable
your money is valuable you shouldn't be
wasting them driving to the brick and
mortar auto parts store which is going
to take you 15 minutes at least to drive
to you're going to go in they're going
to get pepper you with questions that
what make what year what model what this
what that they're going to go in the
back they're not going to have the part
there's too many parts to stock these
days and so they say we're going to have
to order the part okay we'll let you
know when it's in
it's gonna take what
four days five days with this supply
chain probably two weeks you drive back
that's another 15 minutes you drive back
to the store it's another 15 minutes you
go and you but don't do it oh and then
by the way you have the privilege of
paying 30 40 100 more sometimes these
parts you can go to rockauto.com they've
got every part you need for your car
truck no gimmicks same prices for pros
and do-it-yourselfers super easy to
navigate website head on over go to
rockauto.com right now check out all
those parts available that you'll need
for your car or truck write knowles
kwles in there how did you hear about us
box and tell them that we sent you
i'm not the only one who is predicting
that fauci's coming back
i'm not the only one who is predicting
that the covid lockdown
biomedical security state is coming back
do you know who else is predicting it
america's governor the governor of the
the free estate probably in america ron
desantis
they want people to act like okay you
know we're just gonna you know we're
moving on the minute those elections are
over
they will impose mandates if they if
they feel the need to do that they will
impose restrictions and so that will
happen
if those types of people are allowed to
put and be put in power and so you know
my my view on that is they've put fauchi
in the witness protection program
because they don't want because he will
say you know no you still should wear
masks this and he's never going to say
be normal go back to normal and so they
know that and they know that that's not
what people want people want to be able
to make decisions for themselves and
there's nothing wrong if on an
individual basis you make a certain
calculation that's fine we encourage you
to to do that uh but it's wrong to
mandate people and restrict people and
that will happen i guarantee you winner
of 2022
any of those folks that are there you
are gonna see that happen the only way
to make sure it doesn't happen
is to have a nice big red wave so we'll
see
i was so glad to hear desantis say this
because i have been
yelling about this for months now even
as covid as they start to get rid of
some of the mask mandates they loosen up
a little bit on the vaccine mandates
they put as desantis says fouchy into
witness protection i said guys it's a
trick it's a trap i sound like admiral
ackbar don't let them get away with it
they shut your country down for two
years now they're seeing the
consequences of that reflected in their
polls and they're trying to do a jedi
mind trick i don't know why there are
all these star wars metaphors here
they're trying to use a mind trick to to
make you forget about all that and not
hate them so much when you go to the
ballot box in november but they're not
done with it they're leaving all of the
infrastructure in place to exercise this
kind of power again
and then you've got ron desantis who is
one of the shrewdest politicians on the
right in the entire country right now
and he's saying the exact same thing
he's saying don't let them get away with
it they're they're going to bring this
guy back they're going to bring the
whole damn thing back because it's very
helpful to them
particularly when they're not in an
election year when biden first
entered office he was underwater he had
a little bit of a bump
as new presidents do and then he was
very quickly underwater on every issue
because his policies are disastrous so
he was underwater on the economy he was
underwater obviously on foreign affairs
after the debacle in afghanistan
he was underwater on immigration he was
underwater on a lot of the social issues
the one issue that he was still above
above water on in terms of the poles was
covid because people just didn't know
and they trusted the experts and we'd
all been hypnotized for two years
finally he was underwater even on kovid
because people saw the consequences of
these policies it turns out you can't
just shut down the whole economy and
then pay people to sit around and do
nothing that's not going to work you
know what that's going to lead to
massive inflation so people start to see
that massive inflation they say wait a
second this wasn't a very good idea they
see their favorite businesses closing
some of which perhaps they owned or
worked at they say hmm maybe this wasn't
a great idea
they see the effect on their kids
education these kids now are not
proficient in reading they're not
proficient in math they don't know a
damn thing not that they were getting a
great education in the public schools
before covid but after covet it was even
worse
so their the parents are looking at this
are saying wait this is a really
this is bad this is a really really bad
idea
they look at the studies on the efficacy
of masks they say why the hell did we
even wear these masks they look at the
efficacy of vaccines they see studies on
the uh not of the vaccines of the
lockdowns and they say why did we even
do these lockdowns and then yes they
look at the efficacy of the vaccines
they say you told me that the vaccines
were 100 safe 100 effective now you're
telling me for certain groups maybe it's
not totally safe maybe we shouldn't
recommend it for certain age groups
maybe there are going to be some side
effects like myocarditis or like
a nerve damage or like blood clots or
you know it's rare but it does happen
and oh and they're not totally the 100
effective you need a third shot you need
a fourth shot you need a fifth shot for
goodness sakes they look and they say
what have you people done to our country
for two years
and then fauci goes into hiding and then
the democrats stop talking about it they
say oh go look at ukraine
oh hey don't pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain
you're going to see a lot more of that
distraction coming up until november do
not let them get away with it they have
learned nothing
they've learned nothing other than power
grabs were okay that's what they've
learned and they're going to go right
back to that and desantis is completely
right and rand paul is completely right
and i'm completely right so do not let
them get away with it they're bringing
this thing back we have got a lot of
wind in our sails
as conservatives looking forward to
november okay not just on the covet
issue but on everything every single
issue makes the democrats look terrible
it makes the republicans look at least
relatively good because we're not the
democrats okay and nowhere is this true
or obviously you see it on the economy
you see it on gas you see it on the
prices of goods at the grocery store but
this is true even on the social issues
this is true even on the allegedly
controversial
social sexual issues
in florida
back in florida back with ron desantis
there is
a controversial law
according to the mainstream media it's
the don't say gay law according to the
mainstream media
except in reality it's not controversial
at all and it's the parental rights and
education bill and we now have an
exclusive poll here at the daily wire
just taking people's temperature on this
law and this poll say probably over
samples democrats by the way because
we're using the breakdown from the
official count of the 2020 election you
know the winningest election ever for
democrats they got 70 bazillion votes or
whatever they say so we
we certainly gave a healthy sample
of democrats in this poll and it shows
that nearly two-thirds of americans
support
the florida education law the law
they're calling the don't say gay law
which is such a ridiculous moniker the
the bill the law rather doesn't say gay
anywhere and it just gives parents
rights to make sure that their
six-year-olds aren't being indoctrinated
in transgenderism but nearly two-thirds
of americans support this law
survey sample was a thousand people 37
democrats 32 republicans 31 independent
in this
survey
the law the parental rights and
education law
is backed by 69 of republicans 62
percent of democrats and 57
of independents
it's supported by 63 of whites 66
percent of blacks
62 percent of latinos extraordinarily
popular
even this this most radical social issue
is a huge winner for conservatives
do not back down now we have got all the
wind at our sales push forward for what
is right and just and what
so happens to be popular as well
when you want to get responses from
people okay on these important issues
you can conduct really expensive surveys
or
you can just use constant contact right
now head on over to
constantcontact.com i have used constant
contact since i was 18 or 19 years old
i've used it for many many years it's a
digital marketing platform that helps
small businesses and non-profits of all
sizes build grow and succeed with email
marketing contact management industry
leaning list growth tools social media
ads and more constant contact helps
small businesses connect with their
customers find new customers and sell
online all from one easy to use platform
so easy that even an 18 year old little
michael can do it it has helped lots of
i've used it on campaigns i've used it
in non-profits small businesses with a
97 deliverability rate you can rest
assured that your customers and
potential customers are getting the
right message at the right time with a
simple interface constant contacts easy
to use platform makes contact management
easier than ever powerful automation
tools help you send the right message to
the right person at the right time every
time to start your free digital
marketing trial today
visit
constantcontact.com
major
story speaking of transgenderism
speaking of these
pulling on your heartstrings sort of
social issues major story out of ukraine
not the shelling of civilians in kiev
not the
fight of the ukrainian people to stop
russian aggression no no the story that
business insider decided to focus on
how a transgender ukrainian man
escaped russia's invasion
he
he quote unquote says i painted my nails
violet and wore mom's shirt to look more
girly so that's how he now the
transgender ukrainian man escaped the
invasion and i first started reading
that headline you read it kind of
quickly you say hold on why is a a man
escaping the invasion
the way that it works in ukraine right
now
is that women and girls are allowed to
leave
women and children are allowed to leave
but the men have to stay in ukraine
because the men are expected to fight
for their country against russian
aggression
this is the right thing to do and it
happens to be the policy in ukraine so
why is a man escaping
the war why isn't he fight oh right
because he's not a man because when they
say transgender man they mean a woman
who is pretending to be a man
either because she's confused and
believes because of some fantasy that
she is actually a man or because she
just really wants to be a man and she
isn't one but she wants to
pretend either way
she's being allowed to leave because
she's a man
or because she's a woman rather and not
actually a man now she says she painted
her nails violet and wore mom's shirt to
look more girly she doesn't need to do
very much to look more girly she's a
girl
but what what is so striking about this
issue
and it just
drives home everything we have said
about the transgender craze
is
we are told that transgender men are men
transgender women are women there's no
distinction between a transgender man
and a man or a transgender woman and a
woman i don't know why we have that
extra adjective there beforehand because
there's no difference whatsoever they
just gave uh richard levine who is the
undersecretary of health he's a man who
believes that he's a woman is the
assistant secretary of health in america
shows you the state of our country he
just won an award from some organization
to name him one of the women of the year
because he's a woman you go girl you get
it right
so this woman is a man
until it's inconvenient to be a man
this woman is a man until
she
pretending to be he is asked to fight
for her country to do one of the duties
of being a man and then all of a sudden
let's paint my nails and go to a slumber
party because i'm a girl let's go get
some chardonnay on the weekend and she
she flees the country
this is a problem with the transgender
movement more broadly
and
really it's a problem with our society
at the broadest level
we all want the privileges
that other people have
we never want the duties that other
people have
we always we want to be able to do
whatever we want whenever we want to do
it
we that is our view of liberation and
transgenderism at its core is a radical
liberation movement just like all
movements from the left are radical
liberation movements
not just liberation from governments
that's how they began not just
liberation from social convention that's
how it continued but liberation from
nature and biology itself so it's this
radical liberation movement and we
believe to be truly free you need to be
able to do whatever you want to do in
our culture
but this liberation never involves
taking on responsibilities
taking on duty this is i think this is
probably the biggest distinction between
the leftist and liberal view of the
world and the conservative view of the
world
the liberal and leftist view of the
world
looks at the world primarily from
perspective of rights
and entitlement
and on the more radical left end it's
entitlement two things positive rights
my entitlement two
enter into the women's bathroom if i'm
really a man my entitlement to some
health care service my entitlement to
your money and your labor and on the
more modest side of it it's my
entitlement
my right
from aggression my right to life liberty
and property the negative rights right
it's all these rights rights rights
rights but on the conservative side we
look and we say no no i'm not born
primarily with rights
i am born primarily with duty and
obligations i'm born into a family of a
little baby boy i'm born into a family
i have obligations to my family and to
my community and to my country if you
view the world that way then you're
going to stay and fight for your country
but if you adopt crazy ideologies
radical leftist ideologies like
transgenderism you're never going to
look at the world like that and so it's
no surprise
that this transgender man also known as
a confused woman
is fleeing at the first sign of trouble
not so fun to be a man when the bullets
are flying is it it's really fun to be a
man when you get to sit around and smoke
big cigars and sit in the executive
suite and right that's really that's
when it's fun to be a man when the
bullets are flying and the women and
children get to leave and the men have
to stay
then i think we'd rather paint our nails
right but you can't have it that way you
can't the world is not only about rights
and entitlement and fun and privilege
it's about duty and responsibility and
loyalty to virtues that have been
completely discarded in our modern
leftist culture speaking of some of
those virtues i am
unreasonably
interested in the kim kardashian kanye
west skeet davidson drama
it's
i say it's unreasonable because i don't
care at all about celebrity culture i've
listened to like three kanye songs in my
whole life i don't really know what pete
davidson does and i certainly have never
watched even three minutes of a
kardashian show
but i'm really focused on this
because i think as goes the kim yay
marriage so goes our nation so goes our
culture
skeet davidson the guy from saturday
night live
texted kanye west over the weekend
and then he like a little jerk
released the text messages from his
phone
he says yo it's skeet
can you please take a second and calm
down it's 8 00 am and it don't got to be
like this
kim is literally the best mother i've
ever met what she does for those kids is
amazing and you're so effing lucky that
she's your kid's mom this is so pathetic
what a you know i don't use these terms
that are very popular in culture like
beta male and alpha male and all but
like
this is
not alpha male kind of behavior okay if
we're if we're going to use those terms
anyway not
hey hey your wife that i'm shacking up
with she she's a great mom you're so
lucky that you're
actually you're her husband and father
of her children and you're so lucky and
i'm gonna tell you off because i'm just
this little twerp that shimmied into her
bed so anyway he goes and yells at kanye
kanye responds and goes oh you're using
profanity where are you right now and
skeet davidson responds in bed with your
wife and then texts a picture of himself
making a peace sign lying in kanye's bed
really gross behavior looks like a
little demon you know he looks just like
a little
he looks at you not good so kanye
responds
he says happy to see you're out the
hospital and rehab
now the re the reason i mention these
responses in this whole text exchange
kanye who we're told is crazy he's
erratic he's behaving in a dangerous way
he's a harm to himself and others
kanye west is showing
remarkable patience here
some dude texts you and yells at you the
dude who broke up your marriage who's
taking your wife away from you
then he says i'm lying in bed with your
wife
and kanye responds and he says very
calmly i'm glad to see her out of rehab
he doesn't respond i'm going to kill you
i'm coming over there right so i'm glad
you're out of rehab that's actually
showing a great deal of self-control and
patience
then
then davidson responds a few more times
he's like you should try rehab
you're ruining your legacy
and then kanye just responds he goes
you're more than welcome to come to
sunday service
and and davidson doesn't want to go to
sunday service sunday service is kanye's
sort of
kind of christian musical event that he
holds on sundays pete davidson goes why
don't we meet after sunday service i'll
be at the beverly hills hotel we could
have food and talk privately one on one
come on let's do it privately
honeydew says you want to see me come to
sunday service
and then davidson writes like 27 more
text messages whining and crying
kanye is
100 right
kim
and skeet are 100 wrong
and this matters i know a lot of people
say well who cares
we should all care
it's it's just their marriage that's
their private business no marriage is
not a private business marriage is very
much a public business
marriage is the bedrock political
institution when you get married you do
it in public
you go out there's a priest there's at
least a justice of the peace there are
people there you invite your friends and
family even if you elope there's a
witness there have to be it has to be a
public act and when you go to get
married you
make a vow
usually before god
but at least before the political
community and say i will stay with this
person i'm not going anywhere
and
kanye i'm sure kanye's made a thousand
mistakes kim kardashian's probably made
a thousand mistakes pete davidson is
very clearly a mistake
but
kanye is saying i want to bring my
family back together we've got four kids
don't do this to the kids don't do this
to our family let's go bring it back
together and kim kardashian says no she
did a whole magazine spread in my 40s
i'm just going to do what i want to do
i'm going to pursue me that's what i've
got to do no she's wrong kanye is right
we are seeing here not just a clash of
two celebrities three celebrities if you
include skeet
we are seeing a clash of two views of
the world
and i can't believe i'm saying this i
wouldn't have guessed i would say this
five or six years ago
kanye is representing the conservative
traditional view of marriage and society
kim is representing the modern terrible
liberal view
kids are caught in the middle society's
caught in the middle
be on team kanye do not be on team skeet
okay we can't afford it now when you
want to afford good travel i strongly
recommend you check out priceline right
now head on over to priceline.com since
1998 priceline has been the best way for
travelers to book the trip that they
want at the price they can afford
priceline saves consumers more than one
billion dollars every year billion with
a b
so that their customers never have to
miss the moments that matter with
priceline you can save up to sixty
percent on your favorite hotels you can
also get exclusive deals on rental cars
and flights when you save more you can
do more get more wow this view is
incredible more
another round of room service please
more booyah i'm extending my vacation
sorry boss sorry ben
there are a few things that feel as good
as knowing you saved money with the
discounts priceline offers you get that
feeling a lot because when you save more
you can enjoy more you can do more at
priceline every trip is a big deal
priceline knows that every trip is a big
deal so when you're ready to book the
next one check out priceline.com for the
easiest way to get more wow more more
booyah just to name a few things out of
it
we have got the first dw book cover up
the first real dw book 12 seconds in the
dark by sergeant mattingly it's
available now the book is the true story
of what really happened the night of the
brianna taylor shooting
take a listen to this trailer
it was very chaotic it was very quick
instantly i knew i was shot brianna
taylor she was caught in the crossfire
of those bullets as soon as your brain's
registering it's already over the media
got so many things wrong in this case
saying we had the wrong apartment her
name wasn't on the warrant she was shot
and killed in her sleep in her bed these
are lies this is not true and all the
while you're hearing all these outside
influences from athletes and oprah and
ellen degeneres and kamala harris and
joe biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
[Music]
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
raid
the book is available now on amazon or
anywhere you buy books online so go
order your copy today i can promise you
it will sell out also the premiere of
our latest film the hyperions was
nothing short of phenomenal it's
streaming at dailywire.com so if you're
not a member yet now is the time to join
plus if you join right now you'll be
entered to win the red carpet treatment
with you and the cast and crew of terror
on the prairie starring gina carano if
you win you'll get flown out to the red
carpet premiere of terror on the prairie
where you will meet and greet the daily
wire folks and the film's cast and crew
two lucky members will each get two
tickets and their hotel flight premier
car service and exclusive merch all on
us go to dailywire.com red carpet sign
up with code red carpet and be entered
do not worry if you're already a member
just head on over to dailywire.com red
carpet to enter we'll be right back with
a lot more
welcome back to the show
speaking of prominent spats between men
and women in our public sphere
tulsi gabbard and mitt romney are having
a bit of a tiff as you might expect
tulsi is right and mitt is wrong what is
the tiff about it's about something that
we've talked a lot about on this show in
the last couple of weeks
the bio labs in ukraine that were funded
and in part built by the united states
that the official story coming out of
the united states deep state was these
labs don't exist okay they do exist but
we're not involved okay they exist and
we fund them and we built some of them
but it's just for ordinary scientific
research okay it's actually run by the
military but the pathogens that are
being studied or aren't really dangerous
uh oh okay we're they're actually
extremely dangerous and we're terrified
they're falling into russian hands so
that's quite the evolution of the story
we called it out and the minute that you
mention any of this the minute that you
contradict the official narrative coming
out of the american deep state you're
called a putin stooge or a xi jinping
stooge or anti-american or a traitor or
whatever you just you're just pointing
out the facts on the ground that are
that even the state department is now
admitting is true so tulsi gabbard made
the huge mistake of talking about
something that we know exists
here are the undeniable facts there are
25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs in ukraine
according to the us government these bio
labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities
even in the best of circumstances could
easily be compromised and release these
deadly pathogens
now like covid
these pathogens know no borders
if they are inadvertently or purposely
breached or compromised they will
quickly spread
all throughout europe the united states
and the rest of the world causing untold
suffering and death
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens that they
hold need to be destroyed
did you hear anything wrong with what
she said i didn't the facts that she
observed are undeniable at this point
we've we've talked about it on the show
we've brought the documents from the
state department from the pentagon the
labs exist the labs are studying
dangerous pathogens both the state
department and the pentagon now admit
that that's the case do you disagree
with your conclusion that we've got to
secure the labs that if these things
break out after two years of a pandemic
involving a virus that very likely came
from a lab that coincidentally we were
also funding the wuhan institute of
virology after dealing with that
experience for two years even if we
hadn't dealt with it for two years
even if that hadn't happened just
knowing you've got dangerous pathogens
that can can
run all the way around the world
obviously we need to shut down these
labs we need to secure them they're in a
war zone with russian tanks rolling in
could you disagree with anything that
she just said
mitt romney did
mitt romney tweeted out quote tulsi
gabbard is parroting false russian
propaganda her treasonous lies
may well cost lives
now
mitt romney didn't have any follow-up
tweets because he's completely full of
it he's saying it's false russian
propaganda to say that the u.s was
funding bio labs in ukraine
there's nothing false about it it is
true that the russians used the true
existence of those biolabs as propaganda
the chinese used it as propaganda too
but the very best propaganda has a basis
in fact and the fact is the u.s military
was funding these biola and is still
funding these biolabs and has been since
2005.
so that's just a fact
it's not it's not false propaganda it's
a true fact and mitt romney is calling
this woman a traitor an american service
member tulsi gabbard and a former member
of congress calling her a traitor and a
murderer for stating the truth
mitt freaking romney somehow on the
wrong side of almost every political
issue he is involved in these days
and many in the past too i i really
don't want to hear it from the squishes
anymore that mitt romney is some kind of
good guy he's a good guy you know he
might be a little liberal on some issues
but he look he's a good guy he's an
honorable man he's a liar he's an
absolute liar he has no integrity
whatsoever when he ran for senate
against ted kennedy in boston that was
the first time he ran for senate in
massachusetts then he moved to new
hampshire to run for president then he
moved to utah because he lost both of
those races so he moved to utah so he
could finally become a senator but when
he was running for senate in in
massachusetts he was going up against
teddy kennedy he was asked he was he
said he was very very pro-choice right
forget about those little babies those
little babies don't matter he was trying
to enter the united states senate and
then he was even asked about the legacy
of ronald reagan this is the easiest
lay-up this is such a gimme for
conservatives if conservatives want to
get elected in the mainstream way all
you have to do is say i like ronald
reagan i'm going to be the next ronald
reagan and he couldn't even do that
during during his 1994 senate race he
said i i wasn't a republican during the
time of reagan i i was an independent
during the time of reagan i don't want
to be anything like reagan and then what
he runs for president he says i'm the
i'm the reincarnation of ronald reagan
he's just a putts he's just an absolute
rudderless
completely integrity lacking putts okay
and he's going after this woman tulsi
gabbard for telling the truth it's
disgusting kind of stuff and it makes
you wonder
what degree of freedom of speech do we
have in this country anymore what degree
forget freedom of the press even just
freedom basic freedom of speech for a
service member and former member of
commerce congress to
come out and say these bio labs exist
this is a real threat it was kind of
covered up by the government now they're
admitting it's true and it really
changes the calculation in this war in
ukraine and we've got to be careful
about it and the minute you make that
obvious modest true point
you get this guy mitt romney to come
after you and say you're a traitor and
you're a liar and you're a putin stooge
disgusting absolutely disgusting
mitt romney is no different than those
cackling hens on the view as far as i'm
concerned and you saw the view make the
same point just just the other day anna
navarro who's the fake republican on the
view she is one of the hens she she was
on the show and she said that people
such as tulsi gabbard or tucker carlson
or anyone who raises any questions about
the official narrative coming out of the
state department and the pentagon
regarding united states involvement in
ukraine they should be
investigated and prosecuted by the doj
i think doj in the same way that it is
uh setting up a task force to
investigate oligarchs should look into
people who are russian propagandists and
shilling for putin that's being if you
are a foreign asset
to a dictator it should be investigated
you're a foreign asset to a dictator if
you just read documents from the state
department website you're a foreign
asset to a dictator if you point out
that it would be bad if uh the ukrainian
bio labs that we were funding released
botulism and anthrax you you're just a
foreign you should be
prosecuted
that's how we stand up to putin is we
imprison political dissidents for
telling the truth
that that'll show putin you see because
putin he's a really bad autocrat and he
goes after his opponents and he'll kill
them and he'll certainly imprison his
political opponents and so the way that
we've got to fight that is by
imprisoning our political opponents
does that make sense i'm sure it makes
sense on the view doesn't make a lot of
sense to me
and that's what that's just the logical
conclusion of what mitt romney is saying
mitt romney is actually frankly going
further than anna navarro anna navero is
just saying the doj should investigate
and look into this
mitt romney is accusing tulsi gabbard of
treason you can hang for treason
he's saying this woman has committed a
capital offense
disgusting
really makes you wonder really makes you
wonder i i still think that on the world
stage
we're relatively the good guys okay and
we're fighting relatively the bad guys
but when romney says stuff like this
when when anna navarro says stuff like
this it really does make you think
how how much longer are we are we still
the good guys are we the baddies
are we the baddies by chance
and if we are still the good guys which
i think and i hope that we are how much
longer are we going to be able to keep
that up with people like navarro and
mitt romney
this war is something
that the romneys and the navarros of the
world are taking really lightly
you know you just change your profile
picture put up the ukraine flag
and just
do everything to antagonize russia a
nuclear former superpower and pretend
that ukraine is the battlefield for
freedom on earth it's the most western
democracy most pristine government on
earth it's so central to the west's
identity and
and then it'll be and there's no cost to
anything right
there would be no cost to antagonizing
russia well we right now have the u.n
secretary general saying that for the
first time certainly in my lifetime
nuclear war is a real possibility
further escalation of the war whether by
accident or design
threatens all of humanity
raising the alert of russian nuclear
forces is a bone-chilling development
the prospect of nuclear conflict once
unthinkable
is now back within the realm of
possibility
the security and safety of nuclear
facilities must also be preserved
it's time to stop the order unleashed on
the people of ukraine and get on the
path of diplomacy and peace
that is a chilling prospect as the u.n
secretary general says
putin has threatened nuclear war would
he go through with it
i
i don't know i don't know
i'm not i don't think that he's going to
launch armageddon
but would he use a tactical nuke in
ukraine maybe
maybe he would i think the chances of
that are actually relatively pretty high
that changes the nature of warfare as
we've said on this show
world wars have started for less
and it doesn't make you team putin
to urge a little caution here
and to tell people who three weeks ago
could not have pointed out kiev on a map
that maybe they've got to be a little
more circumspect here maybe they need a
little bit more information and maybe
they need to be able to
ascertain what exactly is going on in
this situation before we just call for
aggression and aggression and aggression
without knowing what the next step is
going to be
we call for
canceling russia right we all the
corporations in the world have basically
canceled russia the economy is destroyed
we even went after their central bank
this is an unprecedented tactic in
modern warfare
well what's the effect of that going to
be
you you would hope that the effect is
putin backs down he pulls out of ukraine
ukraine gets to remain a sovereign
country and that's that that would be
that that's the best intention outcome
what's the real outcome putin's
threatening to nationalize businesses
and recreate the soviet union and it
doesn't seem to be hindering him in any
way on the battlefield if anything it
seems to be prolonging things on the
battlefield in ukraine
but we had good intentions right the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
but mitt romney he's got good into anna
navarro they've got good intentions
tulsi gabbard she's a putin stooge i
think tulsi gabbard is exhibiting much
better judgment here
than
someone like romney who's offering all
the preening all the virtue signaling
and none of the actual
solutions by the way by the way a lot of
this
surrounds the question of nato
will ukraine join nato will ukraine join
the eu before 2013 2014 ukraine was a
neutral country then after the
government was overthrown in 2013 2014
ukraine moved much more toward the west
and they wanted to join the european
union and they wanted to join nato and
russia didn't like that very much and
then russia invaded crimea
then ukraine all the more so uh sort of
naturally wanted to join nato and the eu
their countries partially invaded they
realize that russian aggression is a
very real threat but this escalates and
the eu and nato they they play koi and
they play flirtatious so maybe you can
join us maybe you can join us and so
what happens vladimir putin says i'm not
going to accept that and he invades the
country so the war the war is putin's
fault but it was mis mismanaged the hand
was misplayed
by a west that never really wanted to
accept ukraine in the first place and
zelinski just realized that zelinski
just realized he got played
he just came out the other day
just yesterday actually and said
regarding nato i've cooled down
regarding this question long ago after
we understood that nato is not prepared
to accept ukraine
he said this to abc news in an interview
the alliance is afraid of controversial
things and confrontation with russia i
never wanted to be a country which is
begging something on its knees we are
not going to be that country and i don't
want to be that president so he's saying
oh right nato never wanted us in the
first place which is something that
i've pointed out for a long time a lot
of conservatives point out they said
look nato is not going to accept ukraine
they actually can't accept ukraine
certainly since 20 2014
so certainly since the russian invasion
of crimea i'll be more specific
because if a foreign country is
occupying a nation that then joins nato
that automatically triggers the nato
alliance to go into effect and declare
war on the country that was invading the
country that was just admitted so the
minute that ukraine joins nato you get
world war iii
by definition so it couldn't happen it
was never going to happen
we just
sort of played with toyed with ukraine
and said oh maybe it will and so they
contrary to i think their security
interests
played really cozy with the west
and now they're in this major war and
it's going on and on and on
a little bit of knowledge a little bit
of nuance a little bit of prudence and
caution probably could have stopped a
lot of this zilenski just the other day
pointed out that joe biden is most
directly responsible for the russian
invasion after vladimir putin who bears
all the responsibility after him joe
biden is the most responsible
zolensky said
as we've mentioned on the show you know
i hate to say i told you so zelinski
said that if joe biden had not taken the
sanctions off russia specifically off
that russian pipeline nordstrom 2 to go
straight to europe russia would not have
invaded
and then what happens
biden takes the sanctions off russia in
the pipeline russia invades
a little bit
of caution a little bit of prudence a
little bit of nuance would have gone
a long way
and joe biden is absolutely sick
of people blaming him for high gas
prices and for inflation they want he
wants everyone to blame putin
the second big reason for
inflation
is vladimir putin
from the moment he put his over 150 000
troops on the ukrainian border
the price of gasoline in january went up
75 cents
and putin began amassing troops along
the border and guess what the world took
notice
and those who work in the business know
that the market anticipated prices went
up more
and then putin invaded
make no mistake inflation is largely the
fault of putin i love you know the
republic saying it's biden's gas
pipeline but by biden said he's going to
stop the keystone
pipeline and i did
and that's the reason prices went up
folks let's get something straight here
the keystone pipeline was two years away
it had been two percent finished
give me a break
come on give me a break give me a break
so
joe
with due respect please would you give
me a break what he's saying is that gas
prices only went up because putin was
threatening to invade ukraine now he's
being clever here he's not saying it
goes from the moment that putin did
invade ukraine because gas prices were
already going up long before that he's
saying before
right when putin was amassing the troops
the market the market was pricing in
that putin could invade ukraine and
that's why gas prices went up
half true
half
a distraction
gas prices had been going up
for much longer than putin amassing
troops on the border gas prices have
been going up for joe biden's entire
presidency
they
certainly spiked because of the putin
invasion but they had been going up a
lot longer than that inflation had been
going up a lot longer than that why well
you explained it joe you said that
putin didn't need to invade
for the prices to go up because the
market was pricing it in
so why were gas prices and other prices
going up after biden entered office
because the market was pricing it in joe
biden says well
the keystone pipeline was two years out
from being operational
so what effect would that have on prices
the effect is the market was pricing it
in and it wasn't just the keystone
pipeline yes joe biden on his first day
in office shuts down this major pipeline
that would have improved the american
energy sector but he also put an end to
new oil and gas leases
he put a temporary halt on them now he's
got an indefinite halt on them so what's
that going to do to energy prices in
america they're going to go up but those
new gas leases they they were new so
they hadn't it's not as though there was
drilling going on and then buy and shut
them down right but what biden was
saying is no new oil no new gas and so
the market priced it in his own logic
undercuts his argument here
joe biden
bears responsibility for the high gas
prices
joe biden bears responsibility for
inflation by the way it's not only gas
that's causing inflation
printing lots and lots of money has to
do with inflation too
joe biden knows this he's trying to
blame everything on putin putin ate my
homework the buck stops with putin it's
not persuasive at all and so
the white house can't make a sound
argument on this economic or political
or otherwise so they've got to rope in
tick-tockers to try to push their
propaganda for them
why is gas so expensive and why is the
united states inflation rate at a
four-time decade high
i had the opportunity to ask the white
house why gas down the street is seven
dollars and here's what they said
the obvious reason we are getting out of
a two-year pandemic when use goes up
price goes up but the call was
predominantly about ukraine and russia
so how does that relate russia is one of
the top three producers of oil and it is
actually their number one revenue source
now with putin starting this horrific
fight between ukraine and russia nobody
wants to work with him and do an
international trade so with people being
scared of war and limited resources
prices are bound to go up as well for
the people who can't pay seven dollars
for a gallon of gas there's an app
called gas buddy that shows you the
cheapest gas near you as well as a link
in my buyout to donate to the misplaced
refugees of ukraine
i think it's a pretty bad look at a time
when the united states is focusing on
russian propaganda and chinese
propaganda and we're banning the russian
and the chinese propaganda from a lot of
our airwaves i think it's probably a bad
look
to so transparently push our own
propaganda the white house propaganda
through these tick-tockers the the one
good thing you can say about it
is that
we are much worse at propaganda than the
chinese and the russians are
you know
the soviet union
they were some truly some of the masters
of agit prop and propaganda in the
history of the world china's been very
good at it too and the best joe biden
can muster is some
lady on tiktok some lady who i don't
think is particularly expert in
political economies
she she goes out there and says you know
like and i talked to the white house
today she doesn't even hide it you know
the white house had all of us tick
talkers on and told us what talking
points to push so those are my talking
points
and biden's good
so the
the one
thing that can make you
believe there's some hope for america
is our ruling class is so incompetent
joe biden is so incompetent that when
they push their propaganda it's
absolutely transparent speaking of
economic problems i have to get to this
story today before we go
colin kaepernick
colin kaepernick you know he's most
famous for
disrespecting the american flag the next
thing he's most famous for is being okay
at football but he's most famous for
disrespecting the american flag calling
america a terrible racist a horrible
place disrespecting the founding fathers
so colin kaepernick is begging to play
in the nfl again
he says for the past five years i've
been working out and staying ready in
case an opportunity to play presented
itself i'm really grateful to my trainer
who i've been throwing to all this time
but man do i miss throwing a
professional route runners who's working
i will pull up
now this is really strange because
a few months ago colin kaepernick
released a video in which he said that
playing for the nfl
is like
being a slave on a plantation in the old
south and he compared tryouts in the nfl
to slaves going up at auction and then
the rich white owners come by and decide
which one of these burly black men they
want to purchase to make money off of
it's just like it's like playing and at
the time
i said
it's a little weird that colin
kaepernick who has spent every minute of
the last five years trying to get back
in the nfl
would say that working for the nfl is
like being a slave and now we see it
again
we've seen that argument too completely
bogus
absolutely no integrity
no sincerity at all we've just got a
disgruntled former employee who's
willing to tear down the country the
league in the country that gave him so
much because he feels personally jilted
by it because he he didn't quite
make the cut
that is that is what we're looking at
here okay that is that is a social and
political breakdown that one makes it
very hard to project american power
overseas because we've got so much
discord here at home and total upending
of our american way of life of our sense
of rights and more importantly of our
sense of duties okay we're all so
wrapped up in our own
myopia we're all we're also
wrapped up not even just in our own
preferences and interests but in our own
fantasies our own delusions we've got
people running away from their country
because they're they're women who
pretend to be men who want to be women
at the first chance of danger okay well
a man wrapped up in himself makes a very
small package indeed maybe focus on duty
maybe focus on anything outside of you
you will live a better life we will have
a better country i'm michael knowles as
the michael knowles show i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show